when I started paying attention to how
to win on YouTube my channel grew same
thing with like the titling like I loved
sort of artsy cryptic type you know how
like movie titles you don't even really
know what they mean until you watch the
movie that's what I was doing there's
disadvantages like YouTube doesn't know
what you're talking about you wouldn't
come up and search it doesn't know what
Niche you're in you have to be very
specific so I started changing titles
and thumbnails understanding that
balance between as creators being
authentic and loving what we're doing
but taking the time to really learn what
wins on a platform because if you marry
the two you see fireworks a lot of the
times when you do things and you Explore
Learning what doesn't work is just as
important in a lot of ways because it
like allows you to then take the little
pieces that did and build them up this
one is is almost so obvious that it
feels like a cliche but like
storytellers rule the world starting out
like I would put my arm around younger
me and say the tech doesn't matter you
know the looking at all these things and
what other people are doing like none of
it matters if you can tell a good story
you'll win always add value to your
audience the people that are here for
your content it has to be the North Star
sometimes when we forget to ask the
question yeah but is what I'm doing
adding Direct Value to the people who
are going to be consuming it just easy
to lose sight of that and keeping that
front and center is pivotal another kind
of metaphor that I heard from Donald
Miller in his book building a story
brand it's a Star Wars metaphor content
creators YouTube creators people
building a brand whatever it is there's
a tendency to want to be the hero like
I'm Luke Skywalker I'm the guy and he
says no your audience is Luke Skywalker
yuriota you're the one that takes them
by the hand and helps them become a Jedi
you make their lives easier or better
you help them evolve and so keeping that
front and center as you're as you're
creating and sharing and growing your
business again it's it's incredibly
valuable
thank you
what you're about to watch is a sample
from my movement makers training it's
where I train thought leaders to build
their movement make an income have an
impact around the world I train in the
group twice a month and start to bring
in my friends as well to share their
expertise and wisdom if you want to join
us movement makers is the link in
description below and for now enjoy this
clip I've got a special guest Mr Eddie
Pinero here with us he is uh what are
you at right now on YouTube 450 450
000 subscribers on his YouTube channel
and we're gonna dive into some of his
three strategies on how to win on
YouTube so
Eddie Panero ladies and gentlemen what
do you got for us man what should people
what do people need to do yeah so first
of all I'm so excited to be hanging out
when uh Evan asked about the three
things I spent some time yesterday
thinking about it I put myself in the
position of like when I started YouTube
there were three things I I could tell
younger me what would it be so balance
story and audience so the first one
balance being this is big for me so and
it's what Evan was sort of alluding to
the balance between as creators or
people that have Brands and stories to
tell you know being authentic and loving
what we're doing and and creating uh
passionately
while also understanding the parameters
of the platform and how to win in a
specific Arena so when I started paying
attention to how to win on YouTube my
channel grew and like not kind of grew
at like 20x on my channel
I write speeches I like tell stories
about life and epiphanies and look for
inspiration in sort of the day-to-day
things I did that made like three and a
half minute videos like little almost
like little songs
when I started working with Evan he was
basically like look watch time wins on
YouTube the you know if you really want
to grow your channel you have to have
longer videos so as a Creator I had to
ask myself how do I remain authentic and
and do what feels good but also stretch
that so that I can win on YouTube and so
I started writing 10 15 minute speeches
very new to me but the channel grew like
instantly same thing with like the
titling like I loved sort of artsy
cryptic type you know how like movie
titles you don't even really know what
they mean until you watch the movie
that's what I was doing like I could do
that I could continue but
um there's disadvantages like YouTube
doesn't know what you're talking about
it doesn't you wouldn't come up in
search it doesn't know what Niche you're
in you have to be very specific
so I started changing titles and
thumbnails and uh I get saw another uh
substantial growth curve so that's the
first thing it's like understanding that
balance between as creators being
authentic and loving what we're doing
but taking the time to really learn what
wins on a platform because if you marry
the two uh you see fireworks I like that
yeah yeah well no I mean of course I
like it but it's great no it's The Head
and the Heart you know it's like my
language right it's like The Head and
the Heart where if the head is just the
strategies and like here's what you need
to do to win but if you don't love it
you're not gonna win but if you're only
following your heart and there's no
strategy attached to it too then you
don't end up getting the result and so
it's like in that combination of what
you love doing with what is actually
working that you start to get some
significant results and so this is a
challenge for everybody is that in in
any of these strategies that we give you
not just today but in all of all the
movement makers it's figuring out how do
you make it your own and one of my
biggest challenges in my YouTube career
was in working with my agent
in the same each and as Mel Robbins and
Grant Cardone and all those guys he gave
me assignments that stretch me and
that's going to tell stories that like
didn't feel quite right but I still did
them and in the doing of them it's it
was kind of like trying on somebody
else's hat
it didn't quite fit but it got me 80 of
the way there and it gave me a a good
perspective point that then I could take
what he gave me and I just had to add my
own little customization to it and so I
love that what do you call it balancing
like your authentic self and what works
on the platform there you go yeah you
know I can think of of times I've been
on either a little too like the pendulum
swings and I guess it's different
seasons of your life it's okay to be one
more one way or the other but like
before we had gone into like before I
met you when we started talking shop it
was way too far at the left completely
disregarding the YouTube you know how to
win on the platform and then there are
times where like yeah to your point like
you get so into it that you start losing
that creative spark and you can't have
that either
you can approach it from both ways so if
you come up with the great idea or
something like you love doing right I
would love to spend my time doing this
right that's your leading with the heart
and then you got to figure out
okay how do I make this actually work
because
if I don't figure out a way for it to
work then it's just a hobby as opposed
to something that's having a meaningful
impact at the same time though sometimes
I'll come up with things where okay this
is what's really working right now this
is what's really trending right now this
is something that you know we should be
doing but it doesn't feel right so how
do I take that thing and then attach my
heart to it so I think you can approach
it from both perspectives
um
but yeah that matching is super super
important and another thing to pay back
this is so real to me like this hits
home when he's talking about the agent
stretching him and doing like a lot of
the times when you do things and you
explore
like
learning what doesn't work is just as
important in a lot of ways because it
like allows you to then take the little
pieces that did and build them up
um so yeah when he said that I'm like oh
man there's so many times where it's
like I did things in and it I wasn't
quite right but it wasn't a loss because
I learned what not to do when I also was
able to Cherry connect the things that
we like so that's number one balance
balance what's number two item what do
you got uh story this one is is almost
so obvious that it feels like a cliche
but like uh storytellers rule the world
you know and uh starting out like I
would put my arm around younger me and
say the tech doesn't matter you know the
looking at the all these things and what
other people are doing like none of it
matters if you can tell a good story
you'll win
um and and I have just so many examples
of of Life handing me that lesson like
the first six months of the channel I
wrote uh some speeches told some stories
that uh audios horrendous I used an
iMovie at the time didn't know how to
edit it's sloppy it just looks bad
but they did very well and when I
reshare them and point people to them
today they still do well because the
message is on brand it's on point it
connects with people and so yeah that's
like the the biggest thing story always
wins on this platform I had uh another
example is like
it's probably like five years ago
um I wanted to take things to the next
level and I like wanked up with some
buddies and we're like let's go to the
the desert let's go to Utah high
production uh we had drones and trucks
and cameras and wanted to make this
running thing and so excited spent more
money than I had you know and then came
back put it all together released it
the next week I wrote a speech attached
it to a still image cost zero dollars to
make and put it up and it did like 10
times better again YouTube's visual so
like I'm not advocating the still image
thing but like that sort of emphasizes
the point on the second one the story
worked and it the message connected
better and that's was like wow you know
never put the card before the horse
again you gotta have story so uh that's
another one yeah I like it and that is a
great Storyteller if you if you check
out his channel your world within
everything that Eddie
hosts there is his own
content is his own speeches so you've
been doing it for how many years almost
a decade Jesus I know I know it's crazy
you're you're a YouTube veteran yeah
it's amazing so everything that he's
posted is is his own original
creation so then he will put b-roll and
music and photography and everything
else on top of it if you want to be a
speaker and you're doing speeches then
the story becomes critical to you can't
have a speech without a great story yeah
but for those of you who are doing
coaching or thought leadership kinds of
videos we've talked about the template
for a thought leadership video where it
starts with a powerful opinion context
sentence raise the stakes and then story
so before you get to your advice before
you tell me about the eight ways that I
can lose weight or whatever then you
need to tell me that you understand me
this is the biggest mistake that people
make when they're creating these thought
leadership videos is you're giving me
advice but I don't know who you are
and it's easy for people to look at you
and say well it's easy for you like
great you you already look so skinny or
you already have done XYZ right it's
easy for you you don't understand me
but you do understand them because
you've been through that but they don't
know that because it's their first time
seeing you so that's where the story
becomes really important in every kind
of video so that they know what you've
been through they know that you're like
them and whether it's your story
um something in the news cycle story uh
client story if I if I say a client
story it'll usually change the gender or
change some of the things around it just
not to First identify somebody but the
story is what gets people in to feel
like this person gets me
and then they're willing to listen to
the advice
because without the story without the
connection they won't listen to the
advice so the story part is important uh
to every kind of video whether you're
doing you know speaking videos like
Eddie and your goal is to be a speaker
on stage or any kind of thought
leadership content as well okay so
balance number one story number two so
the third thing is audience and you know
this is truly one of the things that I
think uh Evan is remarkable at and
really inspires me uh to do is is always
add value to your audience the people
that are here for your content it has to
be the North Star and I say this as
someone who like I'm I get so excited
about the journey as we all do like we
we have fun creating and we want to grow
and uh we're looking at the numbers and
we're doing all these things
sometimes we forget to ask the question
yeah but is what I'm doing adding Direct
Value to the people who are going to be
consuming it just easy to lose sight of
that and keeping that front and center
is is pivotal
um another kind of metaphor uh that I
heard from Donald Miller in his book
building a story brand it's a Star Wars
metaphor
um but he says uh
content creators YouTube creators people
building a brand whatever it is there's
a tendency to want to be the hero like
I'm Luke Skywalker I'm the guy and he
says no your audience is Luke Skywalker
your audience they're the heroes yuriota
you're the one that takes them by the
hand and helps them become a Jedi you
make their lives easier or better you
help them evolve and so keeping that
front and center as you're as you're
creating and sharing and uh growing your
business again it's it's incredibly
valuable especially when you're by
yourself in your office or in your car
walking outside and you're just talking
to a camera
doesn't feel
important enough a lot of times it's
right it's like I want to go out to Utah
and do the crazy fancy photo issue and
have where if like I'm just in my office
and I'm filming it doesn't feel
big enough or important enough a lot of
times
and so what uh what I used to do in the
early days was I would imagine one of my
friends an entrepreneur friend who was
struggling
a real guy and I would I would imagine
his face being the camera
and so like I'm not talking to camera
I'm talking to this guy you know I'm
talking to Richard
and in talking to Richard it just
changed the emotion for how I showed up
because a lot of times we're so worried
about uh getting the video out on time
and memorizing our script or getting it
perfect and what's the thumbnail gonna
be like all the tactics and then you
lose the emotion even if it's the best
word you lose the emotion because you're
just kind of going through the motions
as opposed to talking to another human
and it's one of the hardest things to do
is to
feel like you're talking to a human when
there's nobody else in their room
and so that's what I would look at is
I'd imagine my friend Richard there and
I'm talking to him
um the other thing that really helped me
was I would look at some of my comments
before I started filming
uh I would look at what they said I
would look at how uh it inspired them
because so that it feels real
you know even here as we started
um I asked you to put one word for how
you're feeling right now because Eddie
and I were just in a we're just in a
library here in Tempe Arizona right but
there's there's there's people here
right and we're trying to have a message
that hopefully helps you and so in
seeing the activity and seeing how
you're feeling right now uh helps
connect us to what we're doing those are
some of the tactics I guess that helped
me just connect it because being
introverted and shy uh it's easy for me
just to be inside and film content but
if you go back and look at the early
Evan Carmichael videos
it's very robotic and and a lot of what
I say is still what I would say now
there's not a lot of what I said you
know when did I start 2009 it's not a
lot of what I would say back then that I
don't still resonate some of the tactics
might change but the biggest difference
is the intensity and the emotion and the
care
feeling like it's helping somebody as
opposed to just uh talking to a camera
those are the things that work for me so
balance balance story story and audience
and focus on the audience audience your
Yoda they are Luke Skywalker that's so
easy yeah we're we're very young Yodas
but uh
I like it and what's that book building
a story brand by Donald Lawrence read it
like five or six years building a story
brand by Donald Miller yep yeah cool
check it out okay let's bring up Nancy
see your hand first and we'll see how we
can help as I start to develop a new
YouTube channel I heard you talk about
the importance of Storytelling and I
listened to Don Miller's book five times
this year already
um what is it that you do to find things
that inspire you that you know will
connect like how do you
determine what is going to be that thing
that will connect with them so for me
like a few things I've ever known and
what I do is try and be receptive to the
things like if you're looking for
lessons and things you tend to find them
and so my metric is it's for that it's
actually not reverse engineering what I
think will be impactful
um I think what's worked for me is truly
as authentically as I can talking about
the times I got my butt kicked or I won
or I was happy or sad and unpacking it
because what I find is there's a ton of
crossover in in the basic uh life
lessons and emotive experiences that we
have and so if you're telling the story
and then at the end saying and by the
way here's what's in it for you there's
going to be some relatability if it's
helped you it'll help someone else
whether it's a teacher entrepreneur
athlete or whatever so that's really the
lens I focus on it's like
you talk about your experiences through
your own eyes because that's all you can
do and it'll connect and by the way some
people it won't and they won't be the
people that tune in every day to your
stuff you know so that's that's the way
I parse through that yeah I would add uh
whenever you're feeling
heightened emotion
you're on to a good story
how do you do that and not feel scared
to share it well no you have to feel
scared
oh my gosh am I gonna offend Somebody by
going so I really disrupt and I would
say again there's so many great stories
but if you don't feel connected to the
story then it's not going to connect
with anybody else too your emotion is
the thing that you know sells the story
because you love it and one of the
things that I would force Alex to do a
lot is whenever you feel heightened
emotions film whether you post it or not
it doesn't matter just film because what
he would do was get get all you know
happy about something or grape up or
something or or negative emotions like
you're you're pissed off about something
and then we feel like oh that's that
maybe is a good story and then we
say okay well my next filming Day is
next Tuesday so I'll save it for then
and then you show up next Tuesday and
like it's gone right like why was I so
upset at that thing why is this and
you're trying to recapture the emotion
so it's much better to film in the
moment even though your words won't be
perfect
just so that you get the practice of
getting it out of your nervous system
and into the world so that you can even
watch yourself back and say wow that's
what I look like and sound like when I'm
really inspired so anytime you feel
heightened emotion that could be a great
thing for your for your Evernote or your
email as a keeping track of
um well that's a good story that I want
to tell and for the Reps and for the
practice I would turn the phone on
yourself and just
go and and it's not going to be it's
going to be messy but it'll be emotion
filled and even just a practice of
getting it out of your head and into the
world whether you post it or not like
just hearing you say it being able to
vocalize a feeling because that's what
we're doing right we're trying to
vocalize a Feeling
so the practice of vocalizing a feeling
whether you publish it or not is is a
good experience to go through
um and lean into negative emotions too
uh and then the key last part then is
turned into a teachable lesson so you
know somebody cuts you off in the car or
you know you're super grateful for Eddie
for showing up here and sharing some
knowledge or you know the the book
you've read five times it had a big
impact on you and you're actually
feeling it as opposed to just saying it
then you then you can film and talk
about it but then what's the lesson for
me back to the yo you're the Yoda here
you're feeling this okay but then now
how does this impact my life in some way
so I found that a really helpful
practice especially me who's not super
emotive and like to process my feelings
before sharing which makes her worst
videos
[Laughter]
yeah and like if you're scared that
means you're on the right path right
it's not how do I do without being
scared that like because you're scared
therefore you must create last week I'm
always injured right so I'm doing yoga
to help me not be injured I'm Tara why
are you always injured I'm always
injured I don't know why but I'm like I
need to start stretching more and doing
yoga and doing this and I'm just it's
embarrassing at first right I'm like the
guy in the corner that can't touch his
toes and all this stuff whatever but the
teacher says uh it just randomly she
says you belong here in during class and
it made me want to cry like my mind went
to like all the times in my life where I
had imposter syndrome and just felt like
I didn't quite belong and I'm like I
gotta go home and as soon as I got home
I recorded this speech another thing
when you were talking about being scared
right it's like the most vulnerable
thing it's coming out tomorrow the most
vulnerable thing I've ever released to
the point where I sent it to my parents
and I'm like
uh is this like two months like you know
like it just felt like a lot but that's
the type of stuff that's that's
beautiful that really helps people
because you're just putting out your
most vulnerable moments and the lessons
from it and uh yeah
so okay who do we got we got uh Brian in
the house let's go Brian so Evan you
already know my strategy uh it's mostly
to get posting every day I'm starting to
post reels on there but Jessica
mentioned to me that when it comes to
storytelling I have a tendency of going
like too much like because I'm so
excited in the moment it's a spur of the
moment thing I don't come up with a
stories in advance it's just like when
I'm talking about a topic the way pops
up I start talking and then I start
going long-winded she says and then
she's like before you know it's like a
15 minute video became a 45 minute video
or etc etc of me just talking so
I need to learn to tell that down but
what I'm trying to figure out is like
what content strategy should we focus on
because you said Biz Dev but I'm also
trying to get topics out there too of us
and since we're dating coaches for geeks
Gamers and pop culturists
is trying to figure out what
can I share what kind of stories can I
share what kind of stories shouldn't I
share what kind of things should we show
on our show that would capture attention
or what kind of things
it's gonna stay away from my take on
that is uh there's a quote that you are
your own experiment I mean I think
exploration is the way to find out you
know create different things and see
what feels good see what connects and
and sort of work from there your
question is basically
what type of content like how do you
figure out the patterns and the the
types of stuff that you're going to give
to your audience well basically like
we're dealing coaches for geeks and
Gamers so I want to also be able to
touch on some like gaming things going
on in the gaming community and things
like that but it feels like we've been
straying a little bit away from
talking about dating and dating like
different dating topics and we become
more they say we become more gaming
approach with talking about our topics
and stuff like that and just like things
that just pop up in the square of the
moment
yeah it's become like spur of the moment
topics like they get inspired they want
to teach like about maybe about like
recently I've been talking about habits
and how to sustain a 21 day habit you
know building on resolutions which does
sort of apply to dating but it doesn't
like it seems like I'm straying away
from
teaching about dating should I still
continue with doing that because
it seems to be like some people are
coming and some people are starting to
follow but then some people are just
like oh yeah cool leaving comments and
then they're gone I might take as if it
feels right then uh you know and it's
adding value to your audience I don't
think there's anything wrong with that
um you know if you're a gaming channel I
you know I would Advocate primarily
focusing on gaming but I think when you
in other words like when I've boxed
myself in too much
it's like you're you're limiting
yourself in ways that aren't necessary
because there's people I mean people
aren't one-dimensional and I'm sure they
love the the value add in your
perspective on some of these other
things you know like it's I've
continuously placed parameters around
myself and had to step outside of them
uh because you know the world the
world's not black and white you're
multi-dimensional and people people love
it you have to set back to Eddie's very
first point about balance you know you
can start with the head and then bring
in the heart you can start with the
heart and then bring in the head and
this is
the second one where you're starting
with the heart
where you're saying I'm I'm inspired by
habits I'm inspired by this thing and
then
but does it help right so now you just
got to bring in the head
a little more
to say okay I've started these videos on
habits because it calls to me
do like how do I bring this in to now
help my
dating services
right so is there an easy tweak to say
what are the habits that someone needs
to make to be us to get their dating
life in order or to maintain the
relationship that they have so it's not
as generic about how to build a habit
but in the examples that you're giving
like maybe one of your things for how to
build a habit is to create a calendar
great so how do you then apply that to
the data Niche so you're not just a Tony
Robbins talking about habits but we're
bringing it into the dating world
to say okay you you know if you're
trying to get on dates then every
morning go to Tinder or whatever you
know like whatever your advice is or or
every morning if you're in a
relationship uh tell tell your partner
you love them you know or give them a
massage so you're starting with the
heart but there's no head so then it
feels like all over the place random
complete chaos which is a beautiful
place now we just gotta inject some head
right there so that you're using your
brain too to say how do I use this to
help my audience
okay then to the storytelling part I
would say watch yourself back
you know so when you're when you're
flowing and you're saying your story is
for everybody you're flowing you're
telling a story in the moment it's going
to be messy it's not going to be great
not the first time it takes a lot of
practice to get better at it but watch
yourself back it's easy to watch
yourself back and be super critical
you're like oh my God that sucked I took
15 minutes to tell a story that should
be five minutes a lot like we've all
been there right but you're watching it
back with with loving eyes to say okay
here's what I did well and here's what
I'm going to try to do
the next time a little bit better so how
do you take that 15 minute rant and turn
it into a seven minute because half the
stuff you said was you know duplicating
yourself but you watch it back and
that's how you get better like if you
kept going on these Rants and every time
you would watch yourself back and it's
great that you know your partner tells
you that you're long-winded you need to
catch where it's long-winded because
you're the one who's going to be doing
the next story again
and you catch it usually not in the
moment but you catch it afterwards when
I sat down here's a great start so I've
been here in Arizona I've been filming
people if you guys have been watching my
stories I stopped by I'll I'll roll up
on people and be like hey like what's
your message of the day and it's usually
like some long thing as people are like
because they're not used to being on
camera and and it's fine and it's fine
and we go with it right they like
struggling to figure out the mess I come
in here Eddie's here right like hey
Eddie what's your message to the day and
like doesn't know what's happening bang
one lighter he's like all right let's go
Eddie you know he's like because he he's
used to delivering a message that's
tight and concise because he's done this
so many times
um so the more that you practice it but
then watch yourself back the key thing
is like don't lose the heart in any of
this stuff the heart is your advantage
don't lose the heart of the story that
you're sharing don't lose the heart of
the The Habit content or the the thing
that's sparking you to do it we just
need to inject our our brain little bit
more into it too so you watch your
stories back and you see where you can
improve and you inject okay how do I
apply this to the dating niche as
opposed to just going and releasing
there's a way to visualize like if if
when Evan's talking about heart and head
if you look at dating as sort of the Hub
of the wheel like all those things that
maybe in the periphery you know with
story you can always connect the dot
back to the center you know so like if
you do feel yourself wanting to say that
you know I would Advocate looking for
how do you say it in the frame or
context of
dating if that's your thing you know
because you can the spokes of the wheel
like with story you can always bring it
back to the center right yeah so what
part I love it all right thank you Brian
Sylvia in the house who do we got Sylvia
so I am someone who is really good with
telling stories and speaking from the
heart
and I will get on on my camera and shoot
a really good video I'm passionate about
what I teach or
practice until I can share that and I
can connect with the audience
but there's I have no strategy and I
have no Tech so I shoot a great video
I look back at it it inspires me
listening to myself honestly
and then it sits there because like I
don't know I don't know how to get it
out there
and if I hire a VA I don't know what to
ask them or tell them
and sometimes they don't understand what
it is that I am wanting to have happen
so it just it sits there and then I'm
juggling between I am a very passionate
humanitarian and the work I do with
children in Ghana fills me up and then
I'm also really passionate about working
with women and teaching transformation
very in various ways and so I'm doing
both of those
and not doing enough of any because I
know I have so much more to give but I
don't really know how to be out there in
this space and so sometimes I just feel
overwhelmed I can definitely start
because it feels almost exactly like my
situation so you know Evan Aslam been
doing this 10 years seven of those years
like I I felt stagnant and then finally
started to see that exponential growth
similar to you like and by the way it's
beautiful what you're doing you know I I
was uh very into the craft in the art
but like it's like does no one want to
see that like what's going on here let's
go
um and I was able to put some pieces
together I didn't have an admin I didn't
have help or anything like that able to
put some pieces together to see that
growth and I think if you can uh
understand the few simple deliverables
if we're talking specific on YouTube
like you don't need amazing quality you
don't you know you don't need ten
thousand dollar cameras so cell phone is
enough and you really focus on titling
and what other people in that Niche
might click on to to go to your your
video and you look at thumbnails and you
start saying you know they say don't
judge a book by its cover but we're
humans and we do right so how can we
position your your work and your values
so that people do want to click can you
make the videos longer so that every
time someone watches it YouTube goes oh
okay that's a little bit longer watch
time and is more inclined to share it to
more people so to me it feels like a
logistical thing understanding the
logistics and they're they're really not
as hard and intimidating as it seems
that's my advice did you guys notice
that when Sylvia started talking the
whole energy shifted this is part of
your superpower Sylvia being able to
quickly shift you know from the first
word that you came out with somebody's
um emotional state
right you could soak that in caring and
warm I love that you watch yourself back
on video and love it already because it
took me 350 videos until I didn't hate
my videos
you've been watching them back I don't
know how many did it take for you to not
create your style
uh hey I couldn't watch it back
yeah it took me 700 videos until I
inspired myself where I looked back and
thought this was amazing like I'm
starting to get something 700 public
videos so the fact that you're already
there is is amazing I would couple that
with
you know to Eddie's point about
balancing the heart with
what's actually working you might love
the videos that you're creating the
first minute really really really
matters
and people will not give you the
attention uh if the first minute doesn't
really hook in their attention your
version of a hook in is going to be
different you're not going to come by
and say hey guys it's me Sylvia let's go
let's talk about right
you're bringing in with a different
energy which is amazing because a lot of
people are doing that high energy things
and you're different but paying
attention to what happens in that first
minute on watching yourself back will
really matter you know did you did you
say something powerful did you you know
breathe with them did you set the
intention like whatever it is that you
need to do to really yeah you you showed
up and you're getting all this love here
uh without really even trying you're
just being yourself
but if you really focused and we're
really intentional about what you're
gonna say when you start that video it
could even be
more powerful
because you're really your superpower
so how can you with your presence gift
presents to others or with your calm
gift calm to others and narrow it in
that first minute
the tech doesn't make any difference
right to Eddie's point you know this
Tuesday I filmed videos off of this
phone in like that room over there
I have three and a half million
subscribers I do that with the fog and I
then I have it on my computer it's
getting it out to the other people
that I have an issue with I don't know
how to do it if I'm to ask someone else
to do it
I don't know what to tell that kind of
tech I'm talking it's worth knowing like
the absolute Basics so
you go to YouTube
have you uploaded a video yet to YouTube
yes okay so you know how to upload a
video to YouTube great like that's what
we start with
right and if I'm you and I don't know
anything about it I am trying to upload
a daily video
to YouTube for the practice of it to I
don't know how long it takes you to come
up with with a speech or thought or a
prayer or if that just flows really
naturally for you or it takes perfect so
if it flows really natural for you then
every day record a video a morning
blessing an evening prayer a thought of
the day whatever it is just to start
building some momentum around it
um
and upload it to YouTube
even if it's you don't even need the
phone like this is great where you are
right now you you impacted everybody
here
just from your laptop
so you have it here go upload as you
start getting into it we can look more
at
titling at basic thumbnails
it could be something that you
potentially hire or somebody in your
community who ends up watching your
videos and says I love what you're doing
can I help
you don't you don't have to be such an
expert that you tell them what to do
but the thing that's missing is the
momentum
yeah like in the daily creation
you'll get a little smarter in doing it
and the things that feel overwhelming
start to feel less overwhelming
right they give you first start to ride
a bike it feels overwhelming just to get
on the bike
and then it feels overwhelming the pedal
and then oh then you're riding the bike
like my first video took me two days to
make one video just to record it
now I can bang out like 40 videos in a
day what was overwhelming for me the
line moves as you start to swim in the
water a little bit
so in the doing it becomes less
overwhelming and you take the next step
and the next step and the next step it's
not that you're gonna
uh you have to go and become the world's
greatest thumbnail designer
maybe like if you really love it maybe
that becomes something you pick up and
pick on you know you never know until
you do it but
when you start putting in the Reps of
publishing the videos
again one it becomes less overwhelming
as you go until you start building up
momentum so that
if people uh are watching a lot of them
will lend assistance to you as well
they'll say hey have you thought about
blank like no but happy to help you know
like I'm looking for help if you're if
you're good at that
but the the your you know unique ability
is to be able to make the videos and so
nothing should get in the way of you
making a video to spend the message
thank you I'll make the videos amen
pamelize the house hey Pamela what do
you got for us I started doing videos
like three years ago before covid for
real estate agents where I would
interview them and talk about their
businesses and promote them on social
media sites and what happened is covet
hit and then if there was no longer like
a
doing it in person but doing it on zoom
and then I started doing entrepreneurs
so my YouTube channel is kind of like a
mess because I didn't even know what a
thumbnail was when I actually started
doing them so there are a lot of them on
there but my thing is right now um I'm
in the real estate Arena I just did a
real estate course with 16 videos and
they're very short videos explaining
real estate and I'm thinking about doing
a YouTube ad and my question to you is
um it's like how do you do a YouTube ad
what do I start with first as far as you
know doing it out there putting it out
there like I'm like lost as far as the
YouTube ads so what to do first and how
to do it and what am I communicating to
them and do I communicate to them right
on the ad what's going on with the
videos and the price for the ads what
are you selling There are 16 short
videos about the real estate process so
a real estate agent gets into the
business what do they do next they get
their license they sign up with a broker
but no one tells them how to actually do
real estate right and I've been selling
a course for real estate agents right
got it so ads the way it works is you
have your YouTube channel you you upload
an unlisted video to your Channel
okay that would be a sales pitch for
your your course
uh you would then go to add words and
then you can pick your video
uh you could Target either keywords or
you could Target channels
so keywords would be how to get started
in real estate how do I grow my real
estate practice how do you like any of
the any of the Search terms or keywords
that you want to show up against I would
try to think about what agents would be
looking at as opposed to if you just put
real estate as a keyword it'll be a big
keyword but a lot of people who are
searching for that are not your target
audience so you lose a lot of money
quickly so what are the Search terms or
keywords that your target demo are
actually typing in right how do I grow
my real estate practice right those
kinds of things I'm not typing that in
but I might type in real estate or you
could Target specific videos or channels
if somebody has a video or Channel
dedicated to how to grow a real estate
practice
you can put your ad in front of that
video or in front of that channel okay
like you play with both the great thing
the ads are are great and that is it's
an easy way to get tons of eyeballs
it's also an easy way to lose a lot of
money here
and so it's usually the targeting you
know you target two uh too broadly
right you want to narrow it down you
want to pick United States probably
right you don't want world you don't
want somebody in Italy you know looking
at your thing or maybe you do
um but usually the United States is
where most people start Americans will
spend more than anybody else and then
for the actual ad
usually what you would look at is you
have to say something that captures
their attention
so you're hooking them in the first five
seconds is key to make them continue to
watch the ad after five seconds they can
skip but they have to watch the first
five seconds so what are you gonna say
in the first first five seconds to
capture their attention
okay then you are usually using uh an
emotional uh appeal so what's the
emotional appeal what are they
struggling with right now uh you know
you're feeling like you're practicing
isn't growing you're feeling like a
loser because you you know got your
license and like you haven't made a
single sale like the emotional appeal to
then saying and I've got uh an answer
for you it's called My whatever course
there's a link here go click on it so
it's if you're looking for structure
it's hook
in the first five seconds emotional
appeal call to action
okay next we're going to the logical
appeal
the logical appeal is all of the case
studies and testimonials and what do you
get in this thing and there's 16 modules
and what's your reputation and your
history and The Logical buyers right why
it's important is I mean maybe we Dive
In Too Deep In ads but I like this stuff
too uh the emotional buyer will not sit
through the logical stuff but the
logical buyer will sit through the
emotional stuff so that's why you go
emotion first call to action then logic
because the emotion people already
clicked off they go check out your page
the people are still hanging around are
The Logical buyers so yeah but so that's
where you're addressing all of these
things so logical uh buyers and then
call to action again
and then the last section is around
urgency so why now like why does it
matter now why I can do this next week
or next month right like why does it
matter right now whether there's
something in the market that's happening
whether you have a special offer for
your course that's ending soon whether
it's about hitting their targets before
the end of the month like why now and
then call to action again so hook
Target the emotional buyers call to
action Target The Logical buyers call
The Action Target
urgency call to action
okay and that's a good structure for
your ads okay and how long do you think
um it's the actual video should be like
two minutes
you can definitely go longer than two
minutes okay um and the best people
experiment
so that you don't just have one video ad
that's playing you have 20 because you
never know which one's gonna hit that
being said I wouldn't be afraid of going
longer because if you think about it
you pay for the view
like once somebody has viewed the ad
after five seconds you've paid
how long they view does it matter you
don't you're not paying more that
they're watching a three minute ad
versus a 20 minute ad right so if
somebody skips the ad or clicks off and
goes to watch the video cool you've lost
them right if somebody clicks the ad and
goes to your website then you've it's
great that's what you want but if
somebody hasn't clicked yet
and they're still watching
and you stop the video
then they're off to go watch the next
thing right so like they're still
watching why are you not still talking
just take me deeper so I've seen some
like three hour ads because like if
they're still watching why not keep
talking right they're in front of you
you've got a prospect here you're saying
okay well I'm done goodbye and then they
can't find you again right especially
with ads like you can't go back you
can't if they refresh the video that's a
different ad they're not seeing you
anymore so
um you could play with different
likes and and different Hooks and all of
those things could be different and it's
worth doing multiple versions of it so
that you don't have all your eggs in one
basket especially with ads
um but I would not be afraid to go long
uh if you still have something to say we
haven't really taught too much about ads
but uh it's it's the easiest way to get
instant traction but also you're paying
for it so it's a easy way to lose money
too so you make you have to make sure
you're tracking and it's converting
Pablo is in the house he's wearing a
very sexy hoodie what do we got Pablo my
question is that how do you deal with
that when you want to show like a piece
of the movie you know like I'm talking
about negotiation many many times I see
a part of the movie that is is good and
I wanna I wanna show that bottle I want
to show it about the show you know and
um verbal communication no verbal
communication how how can we show it on
this channel we have been flag and and I
have issues
do you have any any advice on that yeah
I mean I I you can probably speak to the
legality more I I uh have especially in
the first couple years of my channel did
a ton of that stuff where I I use uh
b-roll and uh falls under the fair use
umbrella right if you're repurposing it
for educational content uh I've just
sort of moved away from that just
because I want zero risk factor I guess
and it's not integral to what I'm
creating so like
the b-roll can be
anything it doesn't like if I'm if I'm
talking about a specific person or
individual then that's a different thing
but you know my stories are not about a
specific person so I've sort of you know
I used uh
different visuals but yeah and so so
where are you sourcing your your b-roll
from yeah I have uh three stock footage
sites that I use I use um art grid I use
film pack and I use techsmith assets and
they're all priced differently but it
gives me a range of uh it's it's better
than the last thing you want to do is
buy per clip in my opinion you want to
spend seventy dollars on a clip so like
they give you access to nice libraries
that you can pull from and then use that
content in your videos have you seen the
Creator music they just dropped I saw
the ad for it I haven't haven't opened
it up yet so YouTube just dropped a new
thing called Creator music it's on all
channels but it might be on yours if not
it's coming where you can use popular
songs
in your videos and it'll either be off
of a REV share split or you can license
it so you can pay Seven dollars seventy
dollars like whatever the artist sets it
at and then you can use popular songs
inside the videos but to your point
about movies Pablo movies are the
hardest and the worst they're the worst
they're the worst we tried doing a top
10 on I forget who it was uh we could
never get anything through like Harvey
Specter from Suits oh yes right and uh
they flag it oh yeah they just take it
down like it's just it's uh the movie
industry is the worst so does it fall
into fair use sure
you know you you could definitely argue
that but
you've taken to court there's just
unnecessary variables you just have to
think in the court you've taken to court
the movie industry is the worst if
you're if you look at other
channels then it's really up to the
channel you know if I'm profiling Grant
Cardone or whatever
um
Grant could take the video down
Now Grant doesn't want the video down
Grant you know once a video up right
advertise exactly and and everything I
do is always complimentary right it's
not like here is why Grant is a is a
loser or whatever right like it's always
which even great wouldn't care like
Grant would love that yeah
you're into the world of like any
promotion this great promotion uh other
people might not like that right if
you're going to packing somebody but
everything I do is is always uh a
tribute so it makes it easier and we
built it up relationships but that's not
the movie industry we've we've never had
success in the movie industry
um they're the worst at pulling out
content also the music industry we had
this Vibe series for productivity music
and they would always get flagged and it
was just a nightmare to be able to deal
with so yeah big like movie music
I just wouldn't even okay like just talk
to it
um if you look at Charisma and command
that's probably your best bet you know
Charlie
I don't love him okay so Chris are on
credit is probably your best bet well
they'll take like super tight Clips yeah
like five seconds or less
and also if he's using the clip he'll
he'll um
often not include the audio and just
talk over it
so he's talking about uh one of the
things that blew up his channel was the
uh Targaryen was it Lord House of the
the dragon the dragon is that what is it
what was it called lord of the Dragons
House of the Dragons yeah whatever the
targaryens how to negotiate like the
targaryens or whatever
um and so it's like it's really hard to
talk about the targaryens while having
like a man climbing a mountain or
something right because it's
specifically talking about them but most
of that content is video uh but then
they talk over it it's still a risk
right like it could still be taken down
that legally it could be taken down and
legally YouTube won't do anything about
it uh you could legally say it's fair
use but then you're taking HBO to court
right which is I guess
so what is that a Charisma
on command
yeah I saw him that it he he bows you
know he bought these shows and he talked
on top you know yeah and he doesn't get
flat you know what he used to a lot but
that was it like he goes under five
seconds if he's using audio
okay in her video he's talking over most
of it and it's even those are quick
clips like if he's doing b-roll of
Targaryen those those would be really
fast clips too correct me if I'm wrong
but I remember at least the time uh you
said this to me if a big company takes
down your stuff so if it's like a Disney
or HBO that's taking down a clip it's
generally not a copyright strike right
they'll just ask that the movie comes
down which is a big deal like a
copyright strike is not but you don't
want that yeah so the big company is
Movie music they'll block it
or they'll claim it
won't strike you yeah they can't they
can't strike your channel they'll block
it it'll claim it so the claim it means
they'll take all the money from the
video
or they'll block it and then it won't be
there anymore the smaller channels like
Grant can't do that but he could strike
my channel so the smaller channels are
actually the ones that you're more
worried about
okay perfect right like if you use
Eddie's content in your in your video
Eddie could strike your Channel
right you get three Eddie or any strikes
and your channel is gone that's a big
deal you use a bunch of movie clips just
the video's gone
yeah thank you guys cool awesome let's
go all right we got Ida in the house hey
Ida so right now my channel is suffering
and it feels like a mess and the reason
I say that okay I have 200 30 videos and
I'm just a 227 subscribers but the main
thing is I people at a little bit well
not a little like kind of a lot they
were dead because before my content was
mostly Financial education geared
towards newcomers to Canada
and since I decided to Pivot a little
bit and do more like a b to B type thing
and that's like it's the 20 that makes
the 80 difference so I'm getting a lot
of business clients right now who are
inquiring about like taxes
um bookkeeping accounting and that kind
of thing
so my question is and like I'm not
actually taking time to do one-on-one
content like direct to camera content
right now it's more of like coaching
people people who are like okay either
how do I do this and it's mostly that
kind of thing so I'm out of place right
now where I don't know what to put on
YouTube like I have a lot of those
videos because the clients I speak to
it's all it's mostly recorded but I
can't go posting that but I do have a
lot of those kind of videos so what
should I be putting on YouTube how
should I start a new channel because
it's kind of now a business audience
versus an end user audience and should I
like help me there like channels kind of
something right now
I'd be curious to see if your take on
this is different than mine uh but but
my thought is
um because it's a relatively uh new
channel to keep that channel and
continue putting out what you feel is
best with your B2B audience So like
um I have a smaller channel uh that I
it's it's funny like it's 10 years ago
me with an acoustic guitar like playing
music and then uh switches to like
different kinds of music to speaking to
interviews and now back to the stuff
that I'm doing on my it's been a roller
coaster
um and it takes a while obviously uh you
have to be consistent in one of those
things for a certain amount of time for
your audience to understand and want to
come along with you and also equally as
important for YouTube to know what you
are and index you and Nishu so that they
can recommend your video off of similar
videos
um so like my instinct when you say that
is is not to overthink things or I know
like when we're working hard and we're
not getting like that validation it
feels like you know the walls are caving
down or caving in but I feel like this
is truly just part of that creative
process and I think it's something that
you'll be grateful for like this turning
point so you know right now that B2B is
where you're at and people are seeking
your advice on it and you're adding
value and hopefully you're enjoying
doing it
um I would consider this channel now a
B2B Channel and start testing different
types of content the long form stuff
that you mentioned just explore and see
how you can add uh the value to people
the most and as you build that track
record now with this type of video and
start titling and creating consistency
with what you're putting out I think
it's just a matter of time you know when
you get your business going like you
started with the mission content which
is about helping new people you know who
are coming to the country feel welcome
get set up understand their finances all
that kind of stuff there's more Mission
but doesn't pay well because they have
no money because they're like literally
the brokest people coming in right I
mean that's who you love helping the
most so it's got to be at scale now
you've shifted to contents gonna help
you out you grow your business do you at
some point see yourself going back to
the mission content you know like this
is helping you scale your company okay
so now when you scale your company what
what do we do next what's the mission of
Ida and has the mission changed it
hasn't changed it's going to be both so
then just keep going you use the biz dab
show now to bring in
revenue for your business and as you
start scaling the business and can bring
on team
you can invest more into the content
that you love making okay so for the B2B
content right now which I have but I
don't think I can pull it because it's
talking to clients type thing what
content should I be doing should I
should I be doing B2B content I'm
thinking yes
yeah
yeah you might be able to post stuff
from your clients uh clients a little
harder than like prospects who are
coming on if they know it's going to be
recorded it's different than if they
don't know it's be recorded or they know
it's recorded but it's not going to go
up on YouTube right
so it's just setting the expectations
when I did my filming in Toronto some
people fly in to do one-on-ones with me
then that was for a YouTube video I'm
giving you advice but it's gonna be for
a YouTube video so they know that going
in as opposed to it's going to be hard
now to get your existing client videos
to go back and say hey yeah would you
mind if I now use that thing where we
talked about all your stuff and put that
up on YouTube you know it's going to be
hard to get a yes on it but going
forward whether it's clients or
prospective clients or just people who
have problems to be able to see how you
can help them
you have an idea what was the other
channel you made
uh I'd as a podcast it was just a
podcasting channel for the business show
yeah yeah yeah you can even just put it
there like you could put any Biz Dev
stuff because that's still around
um
helping you grow your business side of
things and then the Ida one that's
focused on helping you know people who
are new to the country get set up it
could even be on pause for a little bit
as you're building up
your business I think one of the biggest
things that stopped people from
continuing is it just don't make money
so it's why the biz Dev show becomes so
important is that the biz Dev show where
we're bringing on either potential
clients or potential people who can
refer us clients if you can do that and
it starts to actually help build your
business you build a five six seven
figure business off of it then it starts
to free up time resources to help you
actually build the mission so it's it's
a step it's not the only thing you're
ever going to do for everybody here like
the biz Dev show should never be the
only thing that you do because your
message is so much bigger than just
doing Biz that but you need to finance
your way to be able to make you know the
actual content that you love making
otherwise you never end up making it
it's like a weekend evening thing
usually like if you look at different
channels if it's a completely different
audience it's a different channel so if
the biz Dev stuff is just completely
different content
and the new immigrant stuff is
completely different content then you
can keep Ida to be the the new immigrant
and your podcast show is for your Biz
Dev stuff with Biz Dev we don't even
care how well the videos do the point is
to build the relationships with people
that then leads to sales for your
company if it's a mess it's okay and if
you're feeling overwhelmed it's okay and
if you're not dedicated to making the
the mission content consistently now
that's okay when you feel called to it
make it but you're coming back to it and
it's going to be a big deal
and if you're focused on building the
business to help free up the funds and
resources that's okay I think I could
actually use the same one because I'm
thinking about the course I made this
morning I spoke to about four people
already this morning and they're kind of
newcomers they have all just started
their businesses because like okay I
give a presentation two days ago to a
group of travel nurses in Canada and
they have all started their companies
and they know nothing what to do so it's
basically a lot of them are newcomers
but they've already started their
companies and their comments like okay
I'm probably going to be taking on the
accounting for all of them and the
things we talked about are things that
can also help a lot of newcomers because
they have no idea what all of that is
but these ones that's a group of people
who actually do have a lot of money
because it's travel nursing but they're
all also newcomers so I think that could
go on the on the same channel and it
will still help the same people even
though it's business it's B2B
yeah as long as you feel it's connected
to the audience like back to Yoda you
know Point number three the the audience
is the hero is this content gonna help
them learn something okay you know and
if you just landed five more sales from
it too it's great you know like that's
the that's the benefit of this strategy
is you do interviews with people they
get to know you like you trust you and
then they want to work with you so
I would love for everybody here to yes
be making content and closing clients as
a result of it as well so you got five
new sales amazing and you got some
content that could inspire people
perfect thank you Demetrius Butler in
the house
let's get him up here Mark bushing is
kind of similar to um fill the uh on
edit
all interferences she didn't actually
make the videos but instead of me making
the videos I'll write the video I tend
to lock down everything
so
um we've been an emotional person like
when I start to speak I get really
emotional about the things that are
coming to my mind and my heart
sticky you're showing this through a
video
how could I do that without making a
video about me
how could I balance that wow in the deep
and emotional thought
um how how do you shut that off
and and um because I tend to talk to
myself a lot I I don't mind talking to
myself like throughout the day just to
and I I'm thinking that I could possibly
have that same issue while making a
video so it puts me in a interfere
to not do the video because I don't want
I've had people tell me in the past that
I just want to hear myself talk
when the things that I I did talk about
are things that could actually actually
help people
so now I'm questioning myself is how
could I really
let out my feelings through a video and
balance my emotions at the same high I
think
to to pull yourself out of it would be
a mistake
um and also you know you want to take
feedback with the grain of salt too
people are saying that you want to hear
yourself talk I mean who knows what
that's coming from and what that means
right it's like staying stay in your own
own world here as you're as you're
making this stuff but you know like I
mentioned earning the tell the reason
people will listen is because it's you
speaking
about your experiences and uh you know
I'm an emotional guy too like that's
that's the place that I usually write
from uh it's it's something that was a
motive or that I I had a reaction to or
learned from and and it's it's not
pointing at people and saying you should
do this hey you can't win unless X Y and
Z there's one way to succeed here it is
no
you're telling stories through your eyes
and saying I got something valuable from
this guys and here's what I think you
can as well I think that's that's not
something you want to avoid that is what
will make you great you know so I don't
think you want to hide plus human beings
aren't uh rational we're not pragmatic
we are emotional we we only respond to
emotion uh so uh yeah I think I think
you're trying to run from the thing that
will that will uh set you apart what
would I add to that I was gonna tell
them to go look at Trent Shelton I mean
yeah Trent is all heart and I think
honestly everybody here
the heart is a thing that will connect
people to you like how do you win as an
entrepreneur it's your heart why buy
from you instead of buying from some big
company that's been around forever
and it's because of your heart because I
feel like you care so the heart is
your superpower I would Echo Eddie's
point for anybody feeling like well
people told me that blank like who are
these people
I mean that's it yeah have they done
what you want to do you know I mean I
remember my first I had this video that
I loved that I I collab with somebody on
and we called the believe and
um some of you know the story from the
book but it was six and a half minutes
long and I remember showing it to
somebody in the industry uh who's who's
helped a lot of thought leaders and he
said
nobody's going to watch a six and a half
minute long video on YouTube
and that I didn't understand how the
internet worked
now granted this is back this is back in
the day this is not now where that would
be a really stupid thing to say and and
I don't know I mean um he was somebody
who I respected too like he had helped a
lot of people
but I liked it and so we posted it and
that video
uh my best fit at the time at a hundred
thousand views in a year this video did
a hundred thousand views in a month
and then went on to do a couple million
views I don't know it's at right now and
if I listen to him then it's not on him
it's on me like I listen to him that's
my that's my fault for listening to him
so especially when the early days who's
telling you that you are talking too
much who's telling you that it's too
much about you
you know and there might be Colonels of
Truth in there you could go back to
Brian uh earlier who you know he's going
on these 15-minute rants for stories and
it and it you know might be rambling too
much cool
but the way through is not to have less
heart
the way through is to just be a little
more strategic with your heart
to watch your video back and in 11 way
critique so you can be better the next
time
your heart for everybody like the
biggest thing missing from most people
is hard when you're filming you've got
heart when you're talking to a client
you've got heart when you're helping
somebody one-on-one but then you go to
camera and it's boring
and so it's leaning Into the Heart more
to feel like this actually matters
that's how most of us are going to win
so if you've got too much heart I
wouldn't see it is that a bad thing we
just need to we need to bring our brain
along for the right as well and watch
your videos back
watch the tape and then critique it in
11 Way Forward but uh yeah I think most
of the people who you're surrounded with
I mean even for me mostly people who I'm
around are not doing what I want to do
their opinions are not helpful in fact
it might be the exact opposite of what I
should do
right your friends your parents your
family they have not done the thing that
you want to do so they might be coming
even they might be coming from a loving
place they might uh they might not
as well but if they haven't done what
you're trying to do then their their
tactics and their advice
uh are meaningless and usually
counterproductive a little quick rant
yeah you're in the house I'm thinking
you know to actually reduce like YouTube
like I'm putting three videos a week and
the title and energy Aesthetics is a lot
and what I was thinking to do is that to
reduce that first also in terms of like
the like you said what's the best of it
like I don't know where they could hold
stable uh so I thought to reduce it to
maybe twice a week or once and DeBary
and my question is like do you think
maybe I should do like one longer video
using the videos or 10 minutes uh in
work uh or also in general I'm asking
are there like certain names if I do
twice a week and they're like certain
days that you recommend uh because I
don't see any really growth from the
channel I I don't think it stores
prepared to the effort but in this case
a lot of my time oh man I can speak back
to the conversations we've been having
for for two years now my understanding
here is you want to
create as much as you can without
impacting quality like on the YouTube
platform
um you know more tends to be better it's
just like uh throwing more darts at the
board uh you know the more value you put
out there uh the better but uh the
second it becomes too much it starts
impacting quality is when uh you want to
really assess you know where that sweet
spot is and and uh you know how that
aligns with what you're doing the story
you're telling uh longer videos again
like I I know I sound like a broken
record that that literally changed the
dynamic of my channel like
20x
even thinking like outside the box it's
like well if I'm writing a 10-minute
speech what happens if I find 10 of
those that are similar and I put them
I've released a three hour video the
other day and it's you know it's it's
gonna outperform everything else uh you
know previously that month so uh yeah
like you want to have those things in
the back of your mind like how to win on
the platform uh long content and as much
as you can without uh you know impacting
the quality of your work
so this this is one of the reasons why I
love Eddie is just a willingness to try
stuff because when when we first started
talking about your Channel
it was all like three minute three and a
half minute four minute those kind of
that kind of range and then what did I
first ask you to do was it half an hour
or an hour the first time you asked me
to put a three hour running video out I
would like those three hours with you I
was like okay I don't want to like the
audience my audience is gonna get mad is
what I said I said No One's Gonna want
to watch that
um and it you know it took it long
videos take a while but after a month it
was the best performing video on my
channel yeah and and I said like hey you
know it's just one video and and you can
blame Evan Carmichael for it if you want
but just like just try it and see how it
goes and that ended up now if you go to
Eddie's Channel any good soap are
popular all of the popular videos apart
from the ones that are like years old
are all hour plus long videos and it's
really made a huge impact just because
he tried it you know you're here I think
for you anytime something feels like
work it's like not when something has to
change you know it's like it's it when
you said work or it's like not worth the
effort then then something has to change
because imagine three more years of
doing the same thing it's just gonna get
you're gonna you're gonna be really
unhappy your your your hair is gonna
look like mine you know like if you keep
working on doing the same thing for
three years and you're not happy I think
the biggest thing
for you is still figuring out like how
do we monetize the thing that you're
doing as opposed to just I want to
inspire people yes I love it and like
how can we start making money doing the
thing because when you're making money
doing it uh it's a lot easier to keep
going and to invest and to hire teams so
that you're not doing everything all
yourself so whether it's coaching
whether it's programs like what is the
thing that ultimately you wanna
sell doing what you're doing
because if we could again start to have
you monetize like Ida did a show with
these travel nurses she gets five new
clients she's growing her business it's
working it's a lot easier to keep going
where most people will quit and give up
not that you will just a lot of people
do there's a there's a woman who I've
been meeting here in Arizona who's a
um you know a friend of a friend and
she's wanting to start a podcast it's
like okay you're going to start a
podcast like a video podcast on YouTube
You're gonna start that you can but you
have to have like a three-year window
like if you just have to if it's just to
build a brand you have to be thinking at
least three year window of making
consistent content because it takes a
while to get started and to build the
brand and to get good at creating the
content and to find your voice and to
build an audience you know if you're not
trying to monetize it then you have to
be thinking I'm being I'm going to be
consistent for three years of doing it
right
I want you to figure out how to make
money right because then it's a lot
easier to keep going so she's selling
keynote speeches and a bunch of other
stuff so understanding somebody's
business model allows it to be easier to
make a Content strategy that helps them
so
uh what you're going through is very
normal I think I'm I'm I was the weird
one also YouTube was not a thing to
become YouTube famous Etc
um
I was just making content because of 40
people aside I I just thought hey for
one person that might be a life-changing
video I was all Mission and just doing
it to do it but I already sold my
company you know and like money wasn't
the I didn't need to make money doing it
I was just doing it to help right now
being able to build a business and hire
a team and have 50 people with me is a
lot easier you know to make a lot more
content Than Me by myself doing
everything like it was at the beginning
but you know if I if I didn't have money
on me and I was just getting started
then it would always be this evening
weekend part-time inconsistent thing
unless I could figure out a way to use
it to serve I'm I'm serious first and
you guys all know that right like it's
heart first
and like in the top five has to be
monetization
because otherwise you you just don't
have you can't serve at the highest
level
so
my challenge to you would be to think
one how do you make it not feel like
work especially if it's just a part-time
side hobby kind of thing for now so it's
not work that it's fun it's creative
because creating art is value in itself
to you like the art it should be a
creation process that I'll still make
videos that are just fun that even if it
doesn't do well it's like that if you're
showing up to your art and it feels like
work that's a problem you know it's a
sign something has to change so how can
you inject more heart into the thing
that you're doing
whether it's longer or not like going
longer could be a great strategy but
again if your heart is not into it then
you're going to feel like it's work
again and then you're going to the
effort's not worth it anymore so how can
you inject more heart into the thing and
how can you
figure out what you want to sell like
what is a program uh whether it's your
own or somebody else's that you could
make a path towards monetization
so that uh when you have money coming in
it's a lot easier to keep going and to
hire team to really help you expand as
well yeah I really appreciate that
Andrew connect like I said I think like
who I did today has nothing to do with
the YouTube so we're really opening uh
thinking about a busy it's open whether
it's coaching or whatever it is uh
because what I what I like serving
people like uh like yeah here at Hebrew
basically it means like so if I could
like be a plus Pat I love it I just
don't I really don't like the editing
where they're asked to go around it so
like you're saying it really I think
about her business that that can create
an outcome that I could go to the things
I don't like to someone else yeah
so I really appreciate that but I was
saying until I get there if I reduce it
that's it to two videos a week does it
matter and I really appreciate uh both
of yours your advice but does it matter
what days if like days of the week don't
matter days of the week don't matter
time of the day doesn't matter YouTube
is a long game it's not about unless it
was something news like you're gonna
talk about
the the prime minister in Israel making
a statement for the first time in like
five years or something like that's
really trending has to happen now right
yeah but otherwise it doesn't matter
um and if editing is your problem then
don't edit and just get better like
practice getting better on camera and
speaking where you don't need to edit
because that's a that's a skill that
will serve you more
um in life going from three to two will
it hurt if it's the same level of
quality then yeah it'll hurt being less
consistent
but it's better than doing zero but the
bigger thing is more about like what how
can you make it fun for you to make so
creation should be fun not all of it you
know but like if there's no fun it's
over and how do you monetize it what's
the business model attached to it that's
some good homework for the next two
weeks
yeah I appreciate that thank you very
much but much love here if you want to
join us in movement makers check the
link in the description below otherwise
enjoy this video right here I think
you'll love it